qui dit vrai on va régler une fois pour
tours on sort les graviers alors voici
je vais vous expliquer ce que ça veut
dire 2012 vous avez l'emploi à chaque
mois de 2012 donc douze mois et l'emploi
à chaque mois en 2013 et à chaque mois
bien sûr il ya un niveau d'emploi donc
prenez janvier 2012 par exemple y avait
3 millions neuf cent vingt mille emplois
dans l'économie du québec le mois
d'après on monte à 3 millions neuf cent
soixante mais l'on est monté jusqu'à
quatre millions d'emplois ça c'est au
tour du monde après le mois de mai 2012
alors vous voyez les variations de mois
en mois comme ça est ce que fait
l'institut de la statistique c'est qu'on
fait une moyenne de ses douze mois donc
vous voyez on est dans le milieu là on
est passé de la halle à ça vous donne
une moyenne et on a fait la même chose
en 2013 c'est à dire qu'on à l'évolution
de l'emploi de mois en mois et on fait
une moyenne tout simplement donc quand
vous regardez 2012
regardez comme on est parti baath qu'on
est monté au donc on commence 2013 quand
même assez haut
donc en faisant la moyenne la moyenne
est assez basse pour 2012 alors que 2013
l'emploi était davantage en
dents-de-scie et la moyenne est un peu
plus élevé il est là le 47 mille emplois
de plus dans madame marois pas ce que
monsieur couillard fait c'est qu'il
prend le niveau de l'emploi ici à la fin
de 2013 par rapport au niveau de
l'emploi à la fin de 2012
vous voyez les car ici là il est
d'athènes 4000 emplois ainsi créés 4000
emplois en 2013 si on prend cette
statistique
mais si on prend la moyenne sur la
moyenne il s'est créé 47 mille emplois
messieurs couillard quand il parle de 66
mille emplois perdus ils parlent
essentiellement il parle des emplois à
temps plein et je dois vous dire qu'il
ne prend pas exactement l'année 2013
il prend janvier 2013 à janvier 2000 à
la fin de 2014 donc c'est pas tout à
fait exactement 2013 qui voudra parce
que je me suis dit est ce que vous
m'avez succombé à ses premières séries
n'ont cessé ces cas n'ont rien son
parcours au fusion pour la connerie des
mortels c'est pas évident célia ok alors
vous reculerez la cachette pour me
regarder de nouveau si vous n'avez pas
compris